difficile de faire son métier dans de
telles conditions un concours dans le
plus grand hall du salon de
l'agriculture
et sous les yeux du public à 20 ans elle
a originaire de vendôme doit apprécier
la santé d'une brebis en prenant sa
température ou en vérifiant sa dentition
j'avais du temps entre oujda capitaux de
6 minutes simon des stages se
développer
puisque j'ai tout dit ce concours doit
consacrer le meilleur jeune berger de
france et à la mi journée elsa a de quoi
avoir le sourire
voir ça
dit que j'étais fini première vos
épreuves théoriques et c'est de toute
façon je savais qu'elle allait faire un
métier dans la nature depuis tout petit
donc on n'est pas surpris c'est pas
c'est pas lisse pas une surprise du tout
simplement arrivé ici au salon de
l'agriculture au bout de deux ans de bts
ça fait quand même un peu étrange par m
autre candidat de notre région à s'être
qualifiés moussa originaire de chartres
sa seule présence au salon est déjà une
victoire pour lui car l'essentiel est
ailleurs
et représenter la région centre mais ça
fait deux ans que je suis dans la région
centre et c'est comme
je m'installe dimanche actuellement je
m'attache qui fut tellement à la région
que je me sens chez moi
évalués sur tous les aspects du métier
le jury a une idée bien précise sur les
qualités nécessaires
aux bergers pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
quelqu'un qui va être déjà passionné par
l'élevage qui va être pragmatique qui
met technique ce qui va résonner et
mac y aura ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon l'oeil de l'éleveur qui va être
capable d'identifier rapidement un
animal qui ne va pas bien mais qui
prendre la bonne décision pour un pour
le soigner comme il faut
malheureusement pas de médaille pour nos
représentants
mais la fierté d'être reconnue parmi les
40 meilleurs jeunes bergers de france